hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
were back i'm fornia and today we have
tons of info to talk about that being
jingxuan gameplay lucha gameplay content
of the week arcade mode and tons more so
with that let's get started with today's
video
so first up a little bit of tip bits of
news the pre-order bonus for marching
fire is up and it's only gonna be
digitally and the bonus if you get is
going to be leaf outfits which I will
show on screen now and it's for the
entire faction so if you do want to get
those you can do that like I said you
could download it digitally on their
website and they started edition on
Steam is free until the weekend is over
and it will never go away so you buy it
for free you keep it forever and as well
there's going to be a faction event
order starting if it sounds dumb already
which is to play as many infernal
Dominion games as a Viking hero and then
that will transfer over to the samurai
one and that will be the last for the
event and the bundles are all for every
character meaning you can buy all the
loot of a concept from the event for
your character the mask outfit in the
upcoming email which will be a little
bit later shown in the video but you can
buy all that would steal if you don't
feel like looting all the stuff for the
huge bit of news the first up is our
Kade mode and member a couple days ago
they showed off the trailer but this is
more of an in-depth look you're given
many quests ranging from all types of
gear recommendation it could be like the
level 9 gear score 144 that's basically
the recommend recommendation that it
wants you to be at when you do these
quests and like I said it's gonna be
shown on the right and each one of these
quests that ranges from the lowest gear
score to highest gear soar has a set
number amount of chapters in these
quests and I'm assuming they're going to
get harder and harder the more you go
and as well which is cool you can do all
your leveling in this mode instead of
doing Dominion and duals which is nice
and as well customization specific loop
which also comes from only this Arcade
Mode and here's some of the gameplay of
what it looks like at a lower level
where you're just a simple one-on-one
with with a few buffs but later in the
game this can be turned into a situation
where you fight a boss it surrounded by
minions while you're slowly bleeding all
over your health away so like I said yes
this can be become very simple like a
simple one-on-one as if you were queuing
up in duels but then it can get a lot
harder so you have to figure out your
way and how to plan this stuff so I'm
really excited to see how Arcade Mode
goes and for arcade mode you also don't
have to be and when you do a co-op game
you don't have to have both players have
Arcade Mode if me and a buddy you want
to play the two men Arcade Mode as long
as I have it he does not need it so that
is one really cool thing about Arcade
Mode but yes sadly you do have to buy
this to actually play it it does not
come
with marching fire Jing Jun was first up
here's a close-up of his weapon I think
it's called the Guan now and he's based
off the god Guan Yu here's a picture of
Jing Jun when he's default level one
here and here also some photos of when
he has some armor on him higher ranks at
the I definitely think of looks really
cool customization wise I personally
think is some of the coolest high-level
customization cannot wait to play min
game so def expects some of that content
marketing fighter but Lisa's buffer Jang
Joon he is a heavy character and he has
a few decent combos that are all two
chain attacks and all of his heavy
finishers are unblockable meaning if the
last move in your chain is a heavy
attack it'll automatically be
unblockable in any guard stance he also
has a seafood stance which with which is
what you're seeing on screen and it's to
regen most of his stamina and it can
also be done well out of stamina as well
so basically you want to be fighting in
and once you're low you want to do the
stance and then go back into fighting
the reason he has this is because all of
his moves do a lot of stamina movement
so that's probably why and he's not the
only heavy in the game with a dashing
heavy attack which is an interesting
game changer and you can also feint this
into a light as well from your direction
you're going and it starts your chain
instead of so instead of doing a light
light you could do the dashing heavy
into an into a secondary light and that
would be the same exact thing he also
has a few parry punishes like a swipe
and it chokehold which are pretty
interesting to look at and he also has
some feats which is like an AoE buff for
health and then also another AoE buff
for stamina region and then to end it
here are some executions of him for you
to check out
next up was Nisha and here's a close
look of her weapon I believe it's called
the hook blades this is also a photo of
her at level one armor and then some
more armor when she becomes higher
replica our erupt five all that type of
stuff on to the gameplay she has a
reflex scarf since she is an assassin a
3-chain attack which can become loaded
to anything that you can think of so
basically she has every chain in the
game and since she's an assassin she
also has the D flex which I'll show now
she also has a trap move as well which
is by using the glass waltz or the Jade
pellet move which is a heavy soughing
and a gar break or a zone soft fate into
G B the zone into G B I believe knocks
the opponent down and the heavy stuns
them so definitely keep that in mind and
the dev said that she has a small move
set but a lot of options they said they
didn't show a lot of gameplay but for
the trap move the dev said for the trap
move the only way to get out of this is
by dodging you cannot block it you
cannot superior block it you cannot
deflect it and you cannot parry it or
you're going to be hit by the trap you
must dodge this move the devs also said
that she has a lot of options but a very
small move set which kind of sucks
and they also didn't show a lot of
gameplay for both the characters sadly
but they said that they're going to talk
a little bit more about them later once
the game comes closer to release so
maybe in end of September early October
and for the feet she's more of a 1v1 s
character she has a feet which makes you
do more damage in a one-on-one fight and
she basically has a flashbang feet where
when activated you cannot run or roll
away from her which is really
interesting so those people that like to
run away and to lastly and this here's
some two executions for your viewing
pleasure
[Music]
and the last bit of news today is going
to be the content of the week guys and
the content of the week is basically
going to be a 7,000 steel emo and it's
basically the Hadouken at which I
believe is what it actually is I'm still
confused if it's the Kamehameha from
Dragon Ball or if it's the Hadouken from
Street Fighter either way I must say
it's the Hadouken but it's still a cool
emote and in the last 7,000 steel it'll
only be up for one week and it's going
to be this this Thursday up until next
Thursday when the event is over
and then afterwards it's never gonna
come back until possibly the next time
this event rolls around or maybe it even
won't ever so if you want to get it you
definitely want to get it within this
week or you're never gonna get it again
and that guy's gonna be in debates today
hopefully guys did enjoy this vid but
now the question of the video is now
that we've seen gameplay of T on D
Shaolin Jing June and new sha I won I
want you guys to tell me in the comments
below who you are going to may know just
by showing off this bit of gameplay from
all four characters that we've seen so
far in the ruling faction time of the
comments below if you're gonna main any
of the four and if so which ones those
are gonna be guys gonna be interviewed
today hopefully guys did enjoy I like to
be if he did subscribe for new I cover
the informational side a foreigner that
being bailed soon as hero updates patch
notes and leaks all that good stuff
keeping everybody up to date with all
the news on for honor with that guys my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out like I said waiver yesterday they
could watch the video and peace out
[Music]